I feel like I'm about to take a test
that I studied for my whole life I don't
think that men need sex toys I'm pretty
happy with masturbator I think women
maybe have more specific needs sexually
than men do for me you know I can like
bump into a table and have it orgasm
dicks aren't complicated Cobra Libre -
am I gonna understand this one if I
haven't used the Cobra Libre one I mean
it looks like a Tron light-cycle they
put the head of your penis in here kind
of like turning my penis into pain and I
feel like it's just gonna make me
dehydrated oh and they get right to it
okay well this feels a little
objectified this is like my fantasy of
being with mystique from the x-men
except for she's not there and I'm
putting my penis and a cup uh it's not
really Pleasant no I guess I get it now
this looks like the prop a prop from a
Cronenberg movie this is why there's a
stigma because this when we're left to
our own devices this is the kind of
we do with it
I can't wait to use it though
I really had to put my dick in this kind
of it looks like like like Mac from Mac
and me okay okay I get it now I'm
definitely looking forward to this one
well ah it was an experience like I
wasn't expecting I'm gonna be thinking
about this for the rest of my life it
was a really humiliating experience for
me and probably the fleshlight the alien
blue flashlight was I don't feel like I
would use it again but I'm certainly not
throwing it out I don't know if I'm
feminine anymore
I don't know if I can call myself that
and it's cold something about like how
detached from sex it is is weird
absolutely understand why there's a
stigma this experience definitely took
away a lot of the stigma from it for me
because now I have had sex with the
Machine I can't go back it was actually
like a somewhat pleasant like jostling
this I could kind of like recommend in
the sense that like well you know if
you're like bored watching football or
something I could see using these like
with a partner as like just like a weird
way to change things up or whatever I
haven't gone to church in probably 20
years and I I feel the need to go to
church it felt it felt wrong it felt
really wrong so is my face gonna get
blurred out if my mother gets an iPad
for Christmas this year and sees this
her tears will be the lube that the
universe needs for the rapture to
enter it